hoy me levanté con ganas de hablar
acerca de los logaritmos que por ciertos
logaritmos es una de estas ideas
bastante sorprendentes que tienen las
matemáticas aunque el logaritmo sea una
de estas palabras extrañas que hay en
matemáticas y nada común en el lenguaje
que utilizamos cotidianamente como
hipotenusa por ejemplo pero bueno la
palabra logaritmo logaritmo como ritmo
te das cuenta el logaritmo tiene ritmo
bueno ya estoy divagando un poco pero
logaritmos vamos a hablar de logaritmos
y realmente un logaritmo no es más que
la forma inversa de pensar una
exponencial y sé que esto suena muy
metafóricamente hablando así que vamos a
verlo con un ejemplo supongamos que yo
me tomo 2 elevado al cubo 2 elevado al
cubo tú y yo y todos sabemos que 2
elevado al cubo es 2 por 2 por 2 lo cual
es 4 por 2 lo cual es 8 2 2 no z
parece una zeta pero aquí ya tengo un 2
bueno si hablamos en lenguaje de
logaritmos lo único que estoy diciendo
es que el logaritmo
hace dos y digo log abreviando la
palabra el logaritmo el logaritmo en
base 2 de 8 es igual a 3 o dicho de otra
manera
fíjate bien a qué potencia tengo que
elevar el 2 es decir mi base para que me
dé 8 y bueno la respuesta es 3
inclusive te lo podrían poner así los 2
de 8 quién es y en ese momento tú
piensas haber 2 elevado a qué potencia
me da 8 pues dos por dos es cuatro por
dos es 8 por lo tanto son 32 elevado a
la potencia 3 es igual a 8 y entonces
ponemos de respuesta 3 y si te das
cuenta es hablar de la función
exponencial de la misma función
exponencial solamente que he visto de
una manera distinta por ejemplo vamos a
ver así que mejor vamos a verlo con otro
ejemplo si yo me tomo el logaritmo el
log en base 4 de 64 ampli te digo quién
es quién es lo que en base 4 de 64 y
nosotros lo que queremos es encontrar el
valor de la equis pues lo que hay que
pensar es el lenguaje de exponenciales y
tal vez es si podemos resolverlo
elevado a la potencia x es igual a 64 4
elevado a que potencian me da 64 y si
nosotros hacemos un poco de memoria me
vas a decir que x tiene que ser igual a
34 elevado al cubo es lo mismo que 64
por lo tanto ya sé que el logaritmo en
base 4 de 64 es exactamente igual que 3
porque 3 es la potencia a la que tengo
que elevar 4 para que me dé 64 es decir
estamos pensando dos cosas muy parecidas
digo el exponencial
digo el logaritmo pero pensado de
sentidos inversos
así que déjenme ver otro ejemplo voy a
borrar la pantalla y ahora voy a poner
un logaritmo a ver un poco más difícil
no voy a tomar el logaritmo en base 10
el logaritmo en base 10 que hoy te la
vamos a poner nombre es el logaritmo de
algo así tremendo como un millón
logaritmo en base 10 de un millón cuánto
es esto así que vamos a decir que esto
es igual a no sé a una pregunta y
recuerda entonces que es mucho más fácil
ver este mismo problema pero pensado en
un lengua
exponencial es decir 10 elevado a qué
potencia me da un millón lo que estoy
buscando es la potencia por lo tanto
pues pensemos lo así 10 elevado a que
pueden ser me da un millón y bueno para
esto hay que contar los ceros no tengo
12 tengo seis ceros por lo tanto 10
elevado a la 6 debe de ser igual a un
millón 10 elevado a la 6 es igual a un
millón recuerda que esta es una de las
propiedades de las potencias de 10 lo
único que hacemos es agregar cuántos
ceros me diga la potencia entonces puedo
concluir y lo que estoy diciendo es que
el logaritmo en base 10 de un millón es
igual a 6 porque 10 elevado a las 6 me
da un millón occupy lsx es de esta
manera 10 elevado a que potencia me da
un millón
la respuesta es 6 la potencia tiene que
ser 6 y creo que ya poco a poco le vas
agarrando más a este lenguaje de
logaritmos así que vamos a ver un
ejemplo un poco más difícil pero no por
eso menos entretenido me voy a tomar el
logaritmo en base un medio
un medio de un octavo cuánto es el valor
de x a cuánto equivale esto y bueno pues
vamos a pasar lo primero al lenguaje de
potencias un medio elevado a la potencia
x recuerda que lo que está después del
signo igual de la potencia tiene que ser
igual a un octavo como que se voltean un
octavo pasa después del signo igual y
equis pasa como potencias y me preguntó
un medio elevado a qué potencia me donó
octavo y me vas a responder que estos
tres un medio por un medio por un medio
es lo mismo que un octavo por lo tanto
ya puedo decir que el logaritmo en base
un medio de un octavo es igual a tres un
medio elevado a la 3 es igual que un
octavo así que vamos a ver otros nuevos
ejemplos y aborde la pantalla y vamos a
ver qué más puedo hacer con otro garitos
y entonces vamos a variar la hora me voy
a tomar el logaritmo en base x de 27
esto igual a 3 y la pregunta es pues qué
base debo de tener ahora lo que no
sabemos es la base pero vamos a
escribirlo en su lenguaje de potencias x
elevado a la 3 es igual a 27 y qué
números y yo le debo a 3
7 bueno inclusive podemos despejar la x
la raíz cúbica de 27 es el valor de x y
la respuesta de estos 33 elevado al cubo
es igual a 27 3 por 3 9 por 3 27 en la
raíz cúbica de 27 estrés y entonces ya
podemos decir que el logaritmo en base 3
de 27 estrés ya encontramos la base
utilizando el lenguaje de potencias por
el lenguaje de potencias es bastante
útil así que vamos a ver otro ejemplo
más este ejemplo me gusta voy a tomarme
el logaritmo en base 100 vamos a poner
una base grandota en base 100 de quien
en base 100 de uno esto es igual
no sabemos logaritmo en base a 100 de
uno es mi pregunta y bueno cómo puedo yo
responder cuánto vale el logaritmo en
base 100 de uno pues igual pensando en
potencias si yo digo que 100 lo elevó a
la potencia signo de interrogación a mi
pregunta esto es igual a 1 entonces voy
a obtener la potencia y 100 elevado a
que putin siempre de 1
pues bueno si recordamos un poco las
leyes de las potencias hay una propiedad
en las potencias que dice que todo
número pero todo el número elevado a la
potencia cero es igual a 1 por lo tanto
si en elevado la 0 es igual a 1 y
entonces ya sabemos cuánto vale el signo
de interrogación el organismo en base
100 de 1 tiene que ser igual a 0 a 0
de hecho el logaritmo en cualquier base
de 1 siempre es igual a cero recuerda
que cualquier número elevado de cero es
uno a ver y qué tal si yo tomo cosas un
poco más extrañas como están el
logaritmo en base 2 de 0 esto a cuánto
es igual voy a suponer que es igual a x
para que no nos perdamos el organismo en
base 2 de cero es igual a x esto quiere
decir que 2 elevado en x es igual a cero
déjame escribirlo 2 elevado a la equis
esto tiene que ser igual a 0 y cuando o
con qué potencia si elevamos 2 a esa
potencia nos da 0 y la respuesta es que
para ninguna potencia 2 al acero es 12
en algunos dos y después crece y para
abajo me salen números muy chiquitos
como
me dio un cuarto un octavo pero nunca me
da cero por lo tanto este lugar y tmo
está indefinido no está definido no
podemos pensar en el otro ejemplo de
esto mismo sería este si yo tengo el
logaritmo en base 3 de menos 1 y me
pregunto cuál es el lugar en un base 3
de menos 1 es decir 3 elevado que
potencia me da menos 1 y la respuesta es
que pues nunca voy a encontrar una
potencia a la cual si 3 elevó esa
potencia me dé menos 1 siempre cualquier
potencia de un número positivo me va a
dar un número positivo aunque yo le
lleva una potencia negativa 3 en la
menos 2 es un noveno positivo por lo
tanto siempre que tenga una base
positiva y quiera sacar el logaritmo de
un número negativo esto va a ser
indefinido como en este caso el lugar y
no en base 3 de menos 1 es indefinido no
hay un valor para ello así que bueno
tengo todavía un minuto y medio y me da
tiempo de hacer mis últimos dos
ejercicios que es cómo acabar el primer
módulo de logaritmos la primera clase de
logaritmos así que bueno voy a pensar en
este logaritmo vamos a tomarnos el
logaritmo en base
8 de 1 sobre 64 a cuánto es igual a esto
y bueno nosotros lo que sí sabemos es
que el logaritmo en base 8 de 64 esto es
igual a 2 porque 8 elevado al cuadrado 8
elevado a la segunda potencia el 64 pues
bueno logaritmo en base 8 de 1 sobre 64
es decir del inverso multiplicativo de
64 es igual a menos 2 la misma respuesta
pero con signo negativo porque 8 elevado
al menos 2 es igual a 1 sobre otro
elevado al cuadrado que esto es lo mismo
que 1 sobre 64 que es justo lo que
quería encontrar el valor de la potencia
tiene que ser menos 2 estoy diciendo que
cuando yo me tomo el inverso
multiplicativo de un número ya esto le
sacó el logaritmo me va a dar la misma
respuesta pero con signo contrario pero
bueno espero que hasta aquí ya tengas
una idea de logaritmos porque aquí se
acaba el primer módulo de logaritmos así
que los siguientes vídeos vamos a ver
más acerca de logaritmos nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo